ganz Amerika ist verrückt nach dieser
Soße schmeckt wirklich genau wie bei
raisin Canes alles was wir brauchen habe
ich hier ich gebe erstmal ein wenig
Ketchup zu unserer Mayonnaise hier dann
folgt ein wenig wtischer Soße ich weiß
jetzt schon wieder dass alle schreiben
dass es falsch ist dabe habe ich es
extra geübt Knoblauchpulver und ganz
wichtig cage and seasoning keine Sorge
falls ihr es bei euch nicht bekommt das
heißt häufig irgendwie Mexican Style
seasoning oder so ansonsten googelt
danach und msert euch einfach durch
außerdem noch schwarzer Pfeffer ruhig
ein bisschen davon und eine leichte
Prise Salz jetzt noch durchrühren und
schauen wie es zur perfekten Soße wird
es sieht wirklich genauso aus wie die
Soße von rising Kanes als ich vor einem
Monat dort war